you have some boiling water what ah and
boiling water when you bring it out of
when you stop it boiling right it's
going to reduce and temperature yeah and
it's going to follow the same kind of
idea we'll be looking at already namely
the hotter it is right the faster it
loses temperature that makes sense right
if we if I make it 200 degrees 100
degrees whatever the the highest
temperature the steeper it will lose
temperature okay so we've got this idea
that right the rate of change here with
deal with temperature okay so since
we've got T for temperature will call
the capital T DT ldt as if ya it's not
your fault that's okay as if I'm rates
of change wasn't complicated enough
without all these letters sent us home
dtt temperatures change over time get
the idea that it's proportional to what
your temperature is right and it's also
it's a decay situation isn't it at least
in this case I'm not making I'm not
warming it up it's getting colder so you
would think that this is the way that
you go right ready change proportional
to your temperature but you might choose
from problems where you try and use this
idea okay because what would an
expression for T would be a common-sense
way to do this we've been doing these
questions a few days right so what would
you say is an expression of fatigue it's
going to be equal to okay hold on I've
got I've got this and I can say all
right that's that's the relationship
between this is actually we called a
differential equation by the way anyway
that's an aside that's relationship
between your quantity you rate of change
why can I get as an expression for that
quantity in terms of time not in terms
of the rate of change well guys this is
the start of a question really simple
what's the function that matches this
kind of relationship
sit here seriously guys go on it's
called exponential growth the decay it's
an exponential function right now it's e
to the power of because it's a decay
kind of situation okay you've got your
minus KT up here right and then there's
something missing well i'm missing I'm
missing a coefficient right so there
ought to be you could call the air you
call it tdawg okay there you go but
there's a problem with this okay I you
can put in your T naught you know
suppose your water starts off its
boiling so Tina would be a hundred or so
like that but what happens is T
approaches infinity hmm this thing is
behaving just like that radioactive
material we looked at yesterday which is
somewhat unsettling um what's it going
to approach as we you know 100,000 years
it's going to approach zero right okay
Nisha is a problem right because at
least for me usually when I take what
off the boil it doesn't usually head
towards freezing point if I just leave
it there okay so what what piece of
information is missing what's missing
let's miss it because this is evidently
or unless you live like in Canada or
something this is probably normal is
going to happen what's what's missing
okay we need to know I better than room
temperature I suppose it's to say
ambient temperature ok what's the
environment like because that kind of
defines what this thing will be right um
this is going to move towards some kind
of the word sometimes we'll see is
equilibrium right that's the point at
which it's like okay I'm happy there I
don't want to increase the temperature I
don't want to decrease in temperature
I'm sort of like this is my comfortable
spot okay now I suppose if you delivered
somewhere where the average temperature
was zero which does exist ok this is
sure enough what would happen if you
leave it for a long time this is what
you're going to get to but we don't live
in one of those areas right even
overnight well ya know we don't really
get that cold even in winter usually
so what do you think the temperature is
today what would you call it 24 22
someone's going to look it up right 22
ok so let's say um let's say the ambient
temperature is 10 22 ok how's this going
to affect what we do here well I hope
you can see that adjusting T naught
which is a concept and adjusting k she's
also a constant neither of these are
going to accomplish this right the
adjustment of this rather ok if we want
to get to land on 22 rather 0 it doesn't
matter what you make your starting
temperature okay it's still going to
this this function is still going to
have to zero and it doesn't matter when
you make your closet of proportionality
you're still going to get 20 just faster
or slower ok so therefore to head to an
ambient temperature how we're going to
change this now what I'm going to
recommend is drew stuff up a set of axes
ok just draw the first quadrant because
for now at least will do in positive
time and just with positive values so
let's let's go with the water being
boiling at the beginning ok so I've
boiled the water and the second I take
off the boil ok the second I taken on
the kettle the stove or whatever ok it
should be let's assume one atmosphere
pressure ok so exactly 100 degrees
Celsius ok so here's my temperature axis
right capital T and here's my time axis
lower t so therefore my capital T
intercept or to be 100 right that's my
initial condition
now if we're going to head towards this
ambient temperature okay it's still
decaying with an exponential kind of
shape right but the difference is like
geometrically speaking there's going to
be a horizontal asymptote right so it's
not going to it's not going to approach
alway 20 unless that is you're over your
temperature okay so if we go with 22
just watch your scale by the way so
wherever you put a hundred i guess about
a fifth or way up that should be rare 22
all right now that's it up the rest of
it behaves just like we normally do
right it starts off losing temperature
very quickly because its temperature is
originally high and then it starts to
drop down okay